so if others heard a scream you wouldn't
that wasn't you no I froze when he slid
between my skis I absolutely froze and I
don't remember yelling or Screaming until
I was very angry at what had happened
okay and so you guys are on the ground
but he was still on the ground right yes when you
said what are you doing yes okay like why did you
do that yes and he said I think you skied into me
yes and that's when you were Furious and said you
skied directly into my effing back your lungs
yes I did okay I have a Giants for my fermented
language you were screaming that so hard you were
worried that Moses was hearing you yes okay and
after you were screaming to him isn't that when Mr
Sanderson said I'm sorry I'm sorry he said I said
you skied directly into my effing back and he said
oh sorry sorry I'm sorry right and that was you
you screaming at him while he's on the ground
still right I was yelling at him pretty loud
pretty forceful I was pretty upset right you're
small But Mighty actually you're not that small um
so when he said I'm sorry I'm sorry would
you agree that he kind of mumbled it yes okay
all right um and then you remember Eric came
over Eric Christensen yes who was Moses's
instructor correct okay and um that was
when you were concerned that oh gosh Moses
is close by he's hearing me yell obscenities
at this man which is not my custom right and
I think you said that and at some point the
man stood up and we were all sort of talking
yes what conversation did you have with
Mr Sanderson standing up I wasn't having
a conversation with him Eric was helping him up
and asking if he was okay okay Eric eventually
right he pulled them up he helped him up he
didn't get up on his own accord he helped
him and were you still standing right there when
he helped him I believe I was yeah you sure you
hadn't skied down a little bit because I might
have skied down a little bit my son was down a
little bit and my now husband came over at some
point okay um so I and I remember moving away from
Mr Sanderson after he collided into me and we hit
the ground okay and do you remember we've heard
from Craig Ramon he was the first individual who
testified do you remember him coming to the scene
I do not you don't remember him at all no you
don't remember him being there or asking you
are you okay I do not okay you don't remember him
asking Terry if he was okay I don't recall okay
all right
and then I think what you've said is
Eric told you I'm gonna handle this
and that's what I think you've said
people do they handle things for you
I don't believe I said that you've never said
that I believe what I said was in the acting
world that's a world of Representatives so you
have an agent who represents you and so if they
say you know I'm going to provide information
you allow somebody to represent you so when
Eric as an accredited Deer Valley Ski instructor
said to me I'll fill out the paperwork he knew
also that my daughter was at the bottom waiting
for me to come for lunch or at the lunch place
and so Mr Christensen handled it for you Mr
Christensen stayed and filled out the report made
sure Mr Sanderson was okay and said to me you can
go ahead how do you know that if you weren't there
because he told me that's what he told you
yes but you weren't there to see it he told
you you can leave he wasn't there objective form I
don't understand go ahead with your questions you
weren't there when the paperwork or the exchange
of information was given fair fair all right and
um would you agree that Mr Christensen did not
see the incident didn't see the Collision correct
he just saw us right afterwards right but in fact
nobody from Deer Valley has seen saw the Collision
correct your kids didn't see the Collision
that's right okay um the only person that
and you may not be aware of this the only person
who says that they saw the Collision was Mr Ramon
yes okay do you the way you answer that makes
me think that you don't believe that he saw it
I did not believe his testimony do
you believe that he saw the Collision
no I don't believe that he saw what he
thinks he saw Miss Paltrow why would he lie
this is a man it's a motive your honor
perhaps that's not the right objection under the
rules so let me be quiet and withdraw my objection
can you answer it he said he was
at 40 feet away and colorblind
I don't know how he can be positive about what he
saw especially with how much he changed his story
well what does colorblind have to do with
anything my husband's colorblind we tease
him all the time but he can't tell red or green
um but what does that have to do with not seeing
who hit who well if you have two people in
ski gear with helmets on and you're 40 plus
feet away I'm not sure how you can discern
who is who okay well and I can tell you that
he didn't because Mr Sanderson categorically
hit me on that ski slope and that is the truth
and I'm sure that that's what you believe I'm not
saying because it's the truth I'm not saying that
um let's get a question so you and Mr
Sanderson if you're almost 5 10 Terry's
five five pushing it your honor that's facts not
in evidence Council you'll have an opportunity
to redirect or to direct examine so if you
two stood next to each other do you think
that somebody would confuse the two of you I I
don't know I'm telling you what happened okay
all right
so you're screaming at Terry worried that Moses
hears you you admit that you were shaken up yes
okay um you don't recall Mr Ramon be eaten
there I do not or asking you if you were okay
I do not did anybody ask you if you were okay
I remember Eric Christensen asking me if I was
okay and Brad my now husband asking me if I was
okay okay and when you talk to Brad he was down
further right yeah with Moses so none of that
took place where my client was he came over to
me after the fall okay and I just want to make
sure you don't have any kind of Medical Training
no okay you don't know what injuries Mr
Sanderson did or did not sustain in the
accident I do not okay are you aware now
that you've sat here the last three days
that he did sustain four broken ribs yes okay
aware that he sustained a concussion yes okay
um are you aware that he had to
be taken down on a toboggan so
clear like does she know as a result of this
testimony or does she know personally would
you clarify your question yeah sure um how
how did you learn that he broke four ribs
through all of this okay and and to
make it clear I don't want to find
out anything that your lawyers told you that's
attorney-client privilege we can't so anytime
I'm asking you I don't want you to tell me
what your lawyers have have told you okay
um through the court proceedings is that
fair that's fair all right you learned that
Mr Sanderson broke four ribs yes okay and
that he sustained a concussion correct okay
that he went was taken down on toboggan yes did
you learn of that that day no did you inquire
what is your name again sorry Kristen yes
sorry I was going to say Kristen sorry
I think you have to keep in mind when
you're the victim of a crash right your
psychology is not necessarily thinking
about the person who perpetrated it
so the answer to my question is no you did not
inquire okay did you ever um ask hey how was that
guy that ran into the back of me is he okay do
you ever ask anybody from Deer Valley about that
I did not because at the time I did not know that
he had sustained injuries like that I thought it
was very minor on the day and you didn't stick
around long enough to find that out I stuck
around long enough for him to say he was okay to
stand up that he told Mr Christensen he was okay